begin with breaking news from Niger
where a group of soldiers claim to have
overthrown the democratically elected
president Muhammad bazum they've
declared the closure of niger's borders
and imposed a nationwide curfew Vernier
car begins our coverage
detained by the men meant to protect him
Nigeria's presidential guard surrounded
Muhammad bazoom's residence early on
Wednesday
amid the uncertainty supporters of the
president came out to protest
no one knows what's going on we all woke
up this morning and heard that someone
had decided to take the president
hostage and try to make him resign it's
impossible everyone has come out to show
their discontent
soldiers fired in the air sending
protesters running
there was apparent Hope from the
presidency and the West African black
ecowas that a solution could be mediated
hours later in a broadcast on National
Television Military Officers announced
the removal of President Muhammad
bazzoon
we the security Defense Forces gathered
at the National Council for the
Safeguard of the Homeland have decided
to put an end to the regime you know
this follows the continuous
deterioration of the security situation
and poor social and economic management
we affirm our support to all commitments
undertaken by Niger
ecowas the African Union and the United
States have demanded president bazoom's
release I spoke with President bazoom
earlier this morning and made clear that
the United States resolutely supports
him as the democratically elected
President of Niger
we call for his immediate release
we condemn any effort to seize power by
force
frustrations around unrest and armed
rebellions in the Sahel region have been
a driving force for coups there
niger's neighbors Mali and Burkina Faso
have seen four military takeovers since
Western forces especially France and the
United States have since increasingly
relied on Niger as a base of operations
against armed groups in the Sahel
they'll hope to see Niger remain a
democracy along with Muhammad bazoom's
supporters who voted him into power just
two years ago
Freddie acar Al Jazeera
Ahmad Idris says there were several
signs of trouble for Muhammad mazum
since he came to power
by Zoom had his work cut out from him
from day one he was an influential
member of the last Administration he
campaigned vigorously and won the
election in 2021 but again in 2021 the
danger sign started showing Brazil is
coming from a minority Arab tribe in
Nigeria and then taking power away from
an established tribe that dominated the
military the Civil Service and the
business was a very very difficult thing
for people and so there were several
indications that this may not end well
for him and it may not end well for his
government I mean running its full
course and we started seeing this
probably since uh
2021 when Muhammad yusu was still in
power that was the time basil was
elected and he was declared President
and there was opposition against him uh
of people who are thinking that they
will certainly be a coup one way or the
other but he lasted two years actually
so he phrase challenges he inherited the
Boko Haram Insurgency the Washington
situation on the border with Mali and
Burkina Faso so those were critical
issues that Define what the cool leaders
were saying in their statement uh this
evening saying that basil has failed to
reign in the security challenges in
Niger and also the economic challenges
facing the people in that country but
again if you look at Nigeria you
understand that this is a poor country
that has been struggling for decades in
terms of the economy in terms of
security in terms of even feeding the
ordinary person on the street Niger has
faced several environmental challenges
climate challenges and is still facing
them and people are are curious to know
how the military will solve those
problems they are accusing Muslim of
failing to solve
West Africa's main Regional and economic
block ecowas had earlier said that the
president of Benin is heading to Niger
on a mediation Mission the U.N the
African Union and the U.S have called
for the immediate release of president
mazum U.S Secretary of State Anthony
Lincoln spoke a few minutes ago about
the political crisis unfolding Indonesia
we are very closely monitoring the
situation and developments in Niger I
spoke with President bazoom earlier this
morning and made clear that the United
States resolutely supports him as the
democratically elected President of
Niger
we call for his immediate release
we condemn any effort to seize power by
force we're actively engaged with the
Nigeria government but also with
Partners in the region and around the
world will continue to do so until the
situation is resolved appropriately and
peacefully
Mike Hannah reports now from Washington
DC
the White House the state department and
indeed the Pentagon have been closely
monitoring the situation there's deep
concern in the United States about the
situation in Niger it is described as a
critical partner of the United States
now there are some 1 000 U.S forces
stationed in that country some of them
special forces units who've been
training the Nigerian military but
there's also a massive drone base in the
north of the country which is used to
police the movement of militants Ally to
Boko Haram or Al-Qaeda so great concern
within the United States also the
awareness of what happened in nisha's
Neighbors at their military coups in
Mali and Burkina Faso resulted in an
invitation to russian-backed forces to
come into the country this is something
that the U.S would not like to see
Indonesia which is regarded as its last
standing Ally in the region now the
Secretary of State Anthony blinken Held
a telephone conversation with president
bazoom during the course of the day he's
in Wellington New Zealand he says that
he offered his unwavering support to the
Nigerian president however what form the
support will take in the days and weeks
ahead is unclear Mike Hanna Al Jazeera
Washington
West Africa has seen a series of
military takeovers and attempted coups
in recent years in August 2020 the
Malian Army ousted the president
after a wave of anti-government protests
three years later the military is still
in power
in September 2021 the soldiers in
neighboring Guinea overthrew a president
Alpha Conde it followed a disputed
election in which she had been vying for
controversial third term
in Burkina Faso two coups took place in
a matter of months in 2022 Army Captain
ibrahimatore is currently in control
there
and also last year in the guinea bassau
11 people were killed in a failed coup
in February
let's bring in that Cameron Hudson now
he's an analyst on African Peace
security and the governance issues he's
also former director of African Affairs
at the National Security Council at the
White House he joins us from Durham
North Carolina Welcome to the program so
still a developing situation here but
nonetheless how worried will the U.S
Administration be over what's happening
well I think they're going to be very
concerned as you mentioned before
there's over a thousand U.S uh military
personnel in Niger right now conducting
counterterrorism operations as well as
training the Nigerian military we have
two drone bases uh operating there which
which uh surveil the entire Sahel region
but more importantly than that I think
it was the last remaining Democratic
state in the entire region you mentioned
the number of coup d'etats that have uh
taken place in the last few years in
neighboring states we've seen secretary
blinken the very first Secretary of
State ever to travel to Niger did so
only three months ago promised more than
150 million dollars in humanitarian
assistance and political support and so
I think there's a real question that
Washington has to be asking itself right
now if after all of this money and
attention and engagement and assistance
if we cannot keep Niger on a democratic
path then and what are we doing wrong
we've seen recent military upheavals in
in neighboring countries haven't we to
what extent have insurgencies like I saw
in the region fueled a military
discontent
well I think we can't rule out the fact
that you know it was the military that
carried out this coup
um and that they have been on the front
lines of combating uh these terrorist
elements that have been spreading across
uh the Sahel region um now Niger was not
the most uh worrisome case it was not
the most beset uh by that terrorist
threat Burkina and Mali have seen far
greater uh death tolls and civilian uh
casualties related to those conflicts
but nonetheless I think there was a
certain degree of uh discontentment uh
within the military uh clearly there's
been some speculation that perhaps they
haven't been receiving uh the training
that they want or the supplies and the
material that have been promised to them
it's hard to say exactly uh what their
grievances are they've been very uh
murky about it just saying uh that it's
the political situation the
socio-economic situation and the
security situation in the country that
caused them to carry out this coup so
that's not a lot to go on given that
it's every thing the U.S says it gives
unwavering support to Muhammad but in
Practical terms how far will that
support go
well again I think we've seen Washington
trying to Rally support not only uh from
its from itself uh but we've seen the
neighboring states uh coming in on uh
Benin and Nigeria intervening uh with
with a mediation effort we don't know
how far that's going to go we've seen
the African Union and ecowas the
regional organization condemning this
coup so there has been I think much more
rallying around uh the Nigerian
president than we saw perhaps in Burkina
Faso or Mali where military coups came
after other military coups bazoom was a
kind of bright spot in this region he
was a democratically elected president
he had embraced uh you know Western
alliances he traveled to France to
Washington multiple times since being
elected had exchanged visits with these
leaders and so it was really seen as the
last uh sahelian leader in the western
Camp I think for him to fall and to be
removed I think poses all kinds of
questions uh for this Alliance of how we
can strengthen and continue to engage uh
sahelian States uh going forward Karen
Hudson we very much appreciate your
insights thank you
thanks